- Y'all all know him as
one of the funniest people
in Hollywood. He has done "Knocked Up,"
"The 40 Year Old Virgin" and "Superbad"
but he's also a crazy good
talented producer and writer.
His new book is a very funny collection
of short stories, very funny.
It's called "Year Book"
and it's out right now,
you gotta check it out.
Give it up for Seth Rogen!
(applause, cheering, upbeat music)
- [Kelly] Hello! How are you?
- [Seth] Hi!
How's it goin'?
- It's goin' all right but
before we get to anything,
I have, I have something to tell you.
- [Seth] Yes?
- Judd Apatow told me that, and
I want to know if it's
true, he told me that
it's your fault that people scream my name
everywhere I go. "Ahhh, Kelly Clarkson!"
(audience laughs)
Everywhere I go, I could
literally do anything.
It doesn't matter how many hits,
what I do in life, I could
save a family from drowning,
fires, I could do anything
and literally the one
thing people know me from
is "Ahhh, Kelly Clarkson!"
(laughter)
- Yep. Um...
- [Kelly] So is this true?
- (laughs) Well, I'm
terribly sorry, first of all.
I owe you, I owe you an apology.
- No, it's awesome!
- It is true, yes!
That is true. It was, I was a co-producer
on "The 40 Year Old Virgin,"
I was also in it but
it was, I was a writer mostly by trade
at the time so I was
hired to write also, like,
jokes, we call them "alt jokes" or
"alternate jokes" and
we knew Carell was gonna
be waxed and he wouldn't be able to think
clearly, probably, so we wanted to just
be able to feed him things to say and
we don't always like
to only have profanity
so, Judd was like, "You
should write a list of jokes
that are, like, dirty jokes
and a list of clean jokes."
And it was hard to write
the clean jokes, and
I honestly think I was
sitting on my couch
writing the jokes and you
came on television.
- (Kelly laughs)
- [Seth] And I saw you
and it was Kelly Clarkson
and in comedy, there's
a thing with like, "kuh"
sounds, like they say
"Comedy K," like a "K" sound
is known for being funny
in the comedy world.
- I didn't know that.
- [Seth] And so,
I saw your name and it was Kelly Clarkson
and there it was! And
there's an actual picture of-
- [Kelly] I'm in between
"Burger Panties" and
"Throbbing Monkey-Tail."
- (audience laughs)
- [Kelly] I like it.
- [Seth] I like how much
of that was, just has to be completely
blurred out because it's not (laughs)
You see, I stuck to
the assignment, though.
Really, of doing one half of clean jokes
- [Kelly] "Throbbing,"
- [Seth] and one half dirty jokes.
"Throbbing Monkey-Tail."
- Yeah, well.
- [Kelly] That's awesome!
- Thank God people
don't scream that at you
when you walk around.
- [Kelly] I am just saying
I loved it so much. I
did, actually. I literally
was coming into a theater,
how I first heard it
was in a preview. I was
coming in to a theater
to watch a different movie
and I was with friends,
we were late because,
you know, I gotta hit up
concessions for some popcorn
and M&Ms. And so we came in
a little late and we were,
like, coming in and I was,
like and everyone was,
like and I thought someone
in the theater yelled
my name. I didn't know
what just happened 'cause
I was like, "What?"
And that's how I found
out. They were like,
"They yelled your name in that trailer."
And I was like, "Why?"
- (audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Anyway, and it's literally
I can be, I can be in
Japan, it doesn't matter
where the hell I am, Seth. People,
"'Since You've Been
Gone?' Never heard of it."
- Nope.
- [Kelly] But Kelly Clarkson's name
being yelled during a waxing?
That's what they know.
It's amazing. But, I, speaking of skill,
you have a lot of skill.
- (laughing)
I've seen your pottery!
- Yes! So you're really good at pottery!
I've seen your pottery on
social media so when did
you start doing that?
- [Seth] Thank you! This is,
yeah, those are some
of my vases. Yeah, this
is a vase I made as well.
- [Kelly] That's so cool!
- I started doing it about two and a half
years ago, I guess? My wife Lauren, is a
very talented, incredible
woman and she's always
done, she's done pottery
since high school, basically,
and she always implored me to try it and,
she said she thought I
would like it, and we
finally took a lesson, and we,
I, I loved it!
I really took to it and we love doing it
together. It was a really
fun activity for us
to, to do with one another.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- [Seth] And, yeah. It's
been great, I love it!
Thank God, because yeah, I mean, who knows
how long they'll let me make movies.
- You have another trade.
- [Seth] Exactly.
- Well, I have to ask you
this. You're both, you said
it's an activity you all
do together. Please tell me
at some point, you've
put on "Unchained Melody"
and totally relived the "Ghost" moment.
- We actually, we've,
there are times, never
that deliberately. We
should. We should do it
just so when we're asked
that question, we could be
like, "Yes, we do it all the time."
- "We are sexy people, yes."
- [Seth] "That's how we bake."
"That mug you're drinking
from right now was
made with me shirtless behind Lauren."
- (audience laughs)
- (Kelly laughs)
- [Seth] "As we interlinked
through one another's hands."
- It was made from love.
Well, here's an idea. If
"Unchained Melody" doesn't
do the trick, you can always
put on "A Moment Like This."
I seem to be an inspiration
for you, so...(laughs)
- You are! You're my muse.
- [Kelly] Seth's new book,
"Year Book," is out now.
Um, what's it about?
- [Seth] It's a collection
of, stories that
I hope are funny, for
people. That's mostly it.
True stories, from my
life. Just kinda essays,
I guess, on subjects as
well that, not so strictly
kind of narrative chapters but, yeah. It's
mostly just, it's pure goal is to be funny
and entertaining, and I'm using my own
personal experiences to try to write,
yeah, pieces that people just
laugh at and enjoy, you know?
- All right, well you talk about meeting
some of your heroes, so
is it true, that Bob Dylan
almost gave you a harmonica and
how does 'almost' happen?
- Yeah, I was at the Grammys once,
years ago. Only once and
the Grammys is a crazy
award show, compared to
movie award shows and musicians lead very,
incredible lives. (laughs)
- (laughing)
- And as I'm sure you've seen firsthand
on many occasions,
if you're a musician, you
can make it that you don't
interact with one human
being you don't want to.
- (Kelly laughs)
- [Seth] Which is, like,
pretty crazy, I think.
But anyway, I was at the Grammys and,
Bob Dylan was there
and he performed and I,
actually stole a drink
from his dressing room,
but I personally didn't see him.
But months, a few months later,
I was at a party and a guy
I know came up to me and
he told me, "You were
at the Grammys this year."
And I said, "Yes," and he
goes, "I was there too
with a friend of mine
who actually looks very much like you
and while we were at the
Grammys, a security guard
came up to him and handed him
a harmonica and said that,
'Bob Dylan is a big fan
of yours on Howard Stern
and wanted you to have
this.'" And I was like,
"Well, can I have the
harmonica?" And the guy was like,
"No. My friend just kept
the harmonica." (laughs)
- (Kelly laughs)
- (audience laughs)
- So, and I don't know who
this person is. I don't
know their name, I honestly
don't even remember
the friend who was the
mutual person at this point.
- (Kelly laughs)
- But if you are watching this and
have the harmonica, please
just give me the harmonica.
- Well, maybe they're a
musician. They don't like talking
to people, Seth so you're never
gonna see it again. (laughs)
- [Seth] Exactly! Maybe they
are completely insulated
from society and will
never see this in any way,
shape or form. (laughs)
- (Kelly laughs)
- (audience laughs)
- You need to go to a country
awards show 'cause I did
grow up with pop award shows
in this industry. Country-
- [Seth] That is probably very different!
- Country award shows are
very different. Everyone's
door is open, they actually
share dressing rooms,
it's a different experience.
Well, you and your
writing partner, Evan
Goldberg, wrote "Superbad."
Was that scene with the beer
in the laundry detergent
bottles from real life?
- Um, it was, again,
another story I reference
in "Year Book" is, uh...
Yeah, we, we noticed
when we were around maybe
16 that a lot of bars stored kegs,
behind...the bar,
and so one night, and I
don't recommend that anyone
do this and I am, confessing
to a crime right now.
- (laughs)
- [Seth] We went out and stole, a keg
from behind a restaurant,
basically, not knowing
that you needed like a
pump to operate a keg.
We knew nothing, we were
children and, we notice
there's like a little
pressure ball that kinda keeps
the beer in so we knocked
it out with a hammer
and then beer just kinda
poured out of it and we
didn't know what to do
so we just kinda filled,
my mother had a lot of
Tupperware parties, my parents
were kinda, they didn't
throw anything away.
- (Kelly laughs)
- We had a lot of empty yogurt containers,
detergent containers,
things like that so we kinda
just filled up everything
we could with beer and also,
we couldn't hide a keg anywhere
so we had to get rid of it.
So, we had to empty the
keg into Tupperware and
things like that, and then
we drank, lukewarm beer
that had been hidden under
out beds in Tupperware
and yogurt containers
and detergent bottles.
- (laughs) Oh, my God.
- [Seth] For the next
several weeks,
unrefrigerated, just sitting
in these plastic tubs, and the fact that
we're still alive is, I guess, a testament
to the immune system.
- (all laugh)
- Oh, my God! (laughs) I
have got to read this book!
You're amazing! Oh my God, it's amazing!
You were destined to be
creative, I'm gonna leave it
at that. So have your
parents read the book?
I mean, speaking of
illegal, did they read it
and go, "What the Hell?"
- (audience laughs)
- [Seth] Yes. My mother read the book and
specifically was like, "Why
do you tell so many stories
about doing drugs?"
- (Kelly laughs)
- That was
her biggest note and
concern, and truthfully,
it made me write a whole
part of the book where I
talk about why I tell so many
stories about doing drugs.
- (laughs)
- [Seth] Because it really
made me think, "Why do I
do this?" But I don't think
she meant it so literally.
I think she was more like,
"Why do you do this?"
But it made me think, "Really,
why do I do this?" (laughs)
- (Kelly laughs)
- So hopefully the book answers
that question to some degree as well.
- And maybe a therapist, okay? (laughs)
- Yes. (laughs)
- So, wait, your mom
tweets a lot, as well.
Oh, I like your cup, by
the way. That's a cute
little mug.
- Thank you! Lauren made this cup.
- [Kelly] Did you make-oh,
gosh! Y'all are talented!
Do y'all sell them? Do
you like have a place
where people can buy them?
- [Seth] No, maybe one day, but
(laughs) not right now.
- Oh, okay. I'm just saying, start an
Etsy page, Lauren. I'd buy
'em! So wait. Did you see
your momma post this 'cause
this is awesome. I'm not
sure if you can see it. Um,
it's about the orgasms in
Bridgerton.
- (audience laughs)
- [Seth] Yes. 'So on
Bridgerton, they always seem
to have their orgasms,' yeah.
Yes, my mother...I don't know
what to tell you. She's...
- (laughs)
- [Seth] This is the lens through which
she views these shows. I,
I don't watch Bridgerton.
That doesn't...I don't know
if that makes me want to
watch it more or less, if I'm
being totally honest. (laughs)
- (Kelly laughs)
- (audience laughs)
- [Seth] It's not
something I want to talk
to my mother about ever so
it's probably better I
don't watch that show,
just to avoid having that
conversation. (laughs)
- I'm just saying, well, you
should tell Lauren to watch it
and tell her, 'You're welcome.'
- [Seth] She, oh, she
devoured that. She watched
it in one weekend, I think.
Yeah. (laughs)
- Yeah, you tell her that library scene...
(comedic horn honking noise).
- [Seth] Oh, yeah. (laughs)
- Yep, all right. (laughs)
- [Seth] She's very disappointed
that guy's not returning for
season two. That's been a big,
big topic of conversation
in our household. (laughs)
- I know, I know, I know. It
is such a great show, though.
I'm excited to watch it again.